Thank you guys all for coming today. Uh,
I would like to present Ruth Whitman,
we're here today to talk about
her book America, the anxious, uh,
why are search for happiness is driving
us crazy and how to find it for real.
Um, as a quick introduction to Ruth is
a British journalist and has contributed
pieces to the New York Times,
The Guardian,
the independence and the Huffington Post.
She previously worked for BBC where she
was releasing numerous documentaries and
in her book she examines what's gone wrong
with American happiness and why it is
leading such an anxious and ultimately
unhappy society and what can be done
about it. Um, my name is Nisha Hoti,
Emma, long time Googler. Um, and yeah,
so do you like to tell
us more about yourself?
Um,
so yeah.
Well we moved to California about six
years ago from the UK and it was quite a
culture shock. You know, my
background is in journalism. Um,
do you want me to tell you
a bit more about, yeah, what
prompted [inaudible]? Yeah,
yeah. Okay. Well, when,
when we first got here,
we came because my husband got a job
working in a tech startup and it was quite
a leap into the dark for us,
you know,
and I had given up my job in journalism
back in the UK and everyday he would
kind of shut the door to going off to
work and I'd have these 12 Calvinists
hours of time to fill before I could
have, uh, an adult conversation again.
And know we had a young baby at the time.
So I was sort of putting myself out
there and trying to make, um, you know,
as many people as I could,
having lots of random conversations with
senior people in the dry cleaners and
the grocery store and you know,
um, in the park with my son.
And I found very quickly that
this strange thing was happening.
I seem to be having the same conversation
over and over again. You know,
different people, different situations,
different, you know, different,
different scenarios.
But the same topic just kept on coming
up and this was some variation on this
theme of happiness.
I painful,
we're talking about happiness almost as
a real source of anxiety in their lives.
You know, people were kind of asking
these really big questions of themselves,
you know, am I happy? Am I happy enough?
Am I as happy as all my friends that
I see on social media? You know,
could I be happier if I was following
my passion? But what is my passionate,
you know,
what did this?
And there seemed to be this real gap
between what people expected in terms of
their happiness and how happy
that actually were feeling.
And you know,
and so I was kind of prompted.
I was really fascinated to do and it
was a real cultural difference because I
think in the UK, you know, happiness
is that a little bit suspect. You know,
you don't want to show too many
overt signs of being too, too,
too happy. So I just was, I
was, I wanted to look into it.
And what I found was that, um, you know,
you would think given the kind of cultural
focus on happiness here in the states
and the amount of money and time and
effort that people put into becoming
happier, you would think Americans would
be the happiest people on the planet.
But statistically, you know,
they actually ranked very,
very far down the list of happiness.
So that was kind of my starting
point for writing this book.
I just wanted to find out why, you know,
what's going wrong and you know, what,
how we could, you know, how,
how we can find out what
really makes for a happy life.
Yeah. Um, one thing that you defined it
in the book, almost like a rat race. Yeah.
Happiness. Um, what did
you mean by that exactly?
Yeah. I mean that the
expression, asset of happiness,
rat race kind of came to me when people
would kind of talk about happiness
almost in the same way that people
talk about going on a diet. You know,
there's not much pleasure involved in it.
But you know,
if I just read this book and do
this meditation App and you know,
go to this in my gratitude journal and
be more mindful and Damon positive and be
well this, then, then I
can be happy. You know?
And it sort of felt like it was really
a lot of hard work, happiness, you know,
there wasn't much pleasure involved in it.
And something that's interesting. You've,
you have had all these experiences,
you've talked to all these people who
seem to be filling their life with all
these measures to become happier. Yeah.
But when you look at it statistically,
if United States,
maybe one of them,
the least happy countries and also our
happiness levels really haven't changed
in quite some time. That's
correct. Right, right. Yeah.
So, um, when you look at
the actual data on this, um,
despite spending more time and money and
emotional energy and trying to kind of
become happier compared to
other developed nations,
Americans as some of the least happy
people and in the Western world.
And actually there was a study
that came out a year or so ago,
which actually put the day
to day contentment of people
in the U S at two places
behind Rwanda. I mean, if you just
think about that for a moment, you know,
Rwanda is a country that has suffered a
major collective psychological trauma,
but yet people that we're writing
is more content than, you know,
American office workers.
So that really kind of,
that was a paradox that made me
want to know more and you know,
find out what was going wrong.
Exactly.
And are there,
are there key differences that you
noticed specifically for moving from
okay to the United States
and whatever that was?
I think that there are a
lot of differences in the
way that people talk about
happiness. I think there's a real
focus in the u s and you know,
I think this is a good thing in
many ways, but there was a real, um,
valuing of people being positive,
you know,
people being cheerful and positive all
the time and appearing happy in a being
happy and also looking
happy to everybody else.
And don't be a Downer and everything.
And I think in the UK maybe people are
a little bit more dated and I actually,
a big kind of negativity is almost
part of the culture in a way. You know,
it's not expected that people would
have such a in a such a high level of,
of, of happiness all the time and people
don't go after it and quite such a
relentless way I think.
Yeah.
So let's take a step back then and
then talk about the book for a second.
Could you give us a brief
kind of quick outline?
I found it really interesting how you
went about examining this rat race. Um,
could you give us a brief outline
of, of what you did? Yeah, so, um,
I did lots of different things.
I spent a lot of time,
I am sound put quite a few of
the south help offerings that,
that people are selling.
You know,
I realize this is south help in this
country is a multibillion dollar industry.
A lot of money is changing hands in this
pursuit of happiness and this and this
idea that we can kind of control our
happiness and make ourselves happier.
So I did the landmark forum. I don't
know if any of you have heard of that,
but it was,
it's a very popular self
help kind of weekend,
four day course that's incredibly intense.
And you know,
I went through everything on this
spectrum of emotion while I was doing that
from sheer terror to
depression, to anxiety, to joy,
to all, all of it. I spent time, um,
with uh, I went to Las Vegas
where I spent time in, um,
Tony Shay, who is the CEO of
Zappos, the shoe retailer.
He has a kind of happiness,
um,
city almost that he's set
up in downtown Las Vegas.
He's bought up a whole load of land and
is running it as a kind of happiness
community based on principles
of positive psychology and um,
you know, on the idea that you
can maximize people's happiness.
And that was a very sort
of strange place to be.
And I spent time with Mormons in Utah.
The moments actually rate as statistically
as the happiest people in America and
but actually what,
what makes this slightly more complexes
that they also have the highest rate of
antidepressant use.
So I was kind of trying to unpick what
was going on there and I looked at the
workplace, some trends and kind of
happiness engineering in the workplace.
I looked at parenting,
social media and I spent some time looking
at the kind of academic research on
happiness, which frankly was the most
joyous part of the whole endeavor.
Academic studies on happiness are
really quite dry. Yeah. And so in,
in listening and reading a good book.
Yeah.
It was really interesting to see how
you jumped from one topic to the next in
this overall vision of what you perceived
the United States to be in terms of
this pursuit for happiness.
Which one of those experiences did
you find to be the most revealing?
Huh? That's an interesting question.
I mean, I think it's hard to pick one.
I mean don't to to spend some time at
the downtown project in, in the, um,
you know, the Las Vegas thing that was
talking about where, you know, this very,
very wealthy tech billionaire has brought
people from all over the United States
to live in this, in this community
and work as entrepreneurs.
And that's this kind of
semi communal living,
a lot of it where they people live and
work in the same place and they've kind
of maximized happiness by,
you know,
putting the buildings in certain
places and the square, you know,
how many people per square foot
and everything is so planned.
And one of the really kind of shocking
things was in this site called happiness
community,
they ended up having one of the highest
suicide rates in the United States.
So I'm in that was a very dark and awful
tragic but also kind of fascinating.
And I think it sort of had partly to do
and a lot of the people that were saying
that it partly had to do with this
extreme pressure to be happy all the time.
You know, the I think really
kind of stress people out.
And that was the thing
that I kept coming back to.
Yeah.
I think it's an interesting topic too
for discussion because in the tech world,
a lot of what we're discussing
today is how can the Internet,
Internet of things
influence your surrounding.
So whether it's your home or whether
it's the city itself that you live in,
how can being surrounded by technology
create a more fruitful life,
a happier life. Um, from your experience,
was that something that was most relevant
to the time that you spend in downtown?
Was technology ever present and did it
cause more happiness or was it rather
something else that calls
people to commit suicide?
I am. I'm in, all of these things
are quite complex. I mean the,
the downtown project,
I mean there was a slight sense at the
beginning that they were going to use
happiness.
That they were going to use technology
even more to kind of monitor where people
went.
And they had this idea that everyone was
going to wear a wristband to measure,
you know, how many social interactions
they had and how happy they were.
And this technology actually exists.
I mean I found that they weren't actually
using this response in the downtown
project,
but they do use them in many companies.
This has become something that your boss
can kind of monitor how happy you are
and how productive you are and
how the two relate to each other.
And there was something very big
brotherish and sinister about that.
And I think in terms of the way that most
people use technology and the Internet,
I mean it's no one thing. I mean
technology is kind of what you make of it.
And I think there's good and bad in that.
I mean I looked at social media was a
big thing that I looked at and I think
that can bring it so, and anxieties. I
think it sort of raises the expectations.
It's the way that we use social media now.
You know,
Instagram and Facebook trying
to make our lives looking quite,
it was almost like a personal
PR project has it, you know,
your Facebook profile
and how happy you look.
And here I am having so much fun and all
these different situations and I think
that in itself has kind of raise the
stakes for anxiety. So many of us,
one of the things that
I really loved about,
and I thought it's so relevant
to my life was two things.
First and foremost tell you, you're right,
social media becomes this PR, right?
It really,
it is your brand and it's unrespectful.
But then you also mentioned in your
book that it's also creating a sanitized
version of your life to
a degree. Right? Right.
And maybe even replacing some kind of
interpersonal communication you have with
other people.
Hi, I'm in. It's kind
of become an Oms, rice.
And I think we all did it to a certain
extent. And I find myself doing it.
Even having written a book about this,
you know,
I find myself doing the same thing. Like,
for instance, you know, when we went,
um, I took my kids apple picking in a,
in a sort of local orchard recently.
Frankly, the day was kind of
miserable. I mean, we did, you know,
the kids were whining the whole time.
It was really hard.
Everybody was kind of butchered.
The APP was rural, mushy.
And then the five times the w
ended up on Facebook of this day,
the one probably many second and the
entire day when everyone was smiling and
posing and whatever.
That's what ended up there.
And anyone looking at that thing
would've thought, you know,
there's what a great day she's having.
And you know what?
I wish my life was like that. Meanwhile,
you know, just sort of thinking,
how come that God that's over,
you know, and it's, you know,
the way that we kind of
curate our lives now,
I think it does give a very
unrepresentative picture
of what happiness looks
like. And I think that is adding
to this anxiety of, you know,
my life really should be like this and
it's on my hair and you know, this gap.
Yeah,
that's very true. Um, one thing
I wanted to touch upon was, uh,
really diving into your experiences
with the self help community.
The landmark forum is kind of
the pinnacle one in your book.
Then there's a few other ones. It's
an elementary schools as well. Um,
and you do a really good job of just
bashing on these forums and these pundits
who really examining in a,
in a,
in a crude way like almost
other swindling people. Um,
what do you think from what you saw
attracted people to the form and then also
it's even ray up and say
like all do level two,
right? Well, I mean this
thing it's, it's also,
I mean I think that the naturally,
the type of people who are attracted
to south help tend to be in the more
vulnerable end of things.
I mean,
you don't go on a self help course
when your life is already bullet in.
I see you,
you know,
you're already dealing with people who
have issues and problems and this is a
business.
I mean this is,
there was a lot of money changing
hands and that it is in these people's
interest to take out as
much money as possible,
which is not to say that everybody in the
south end health industry as some kind
of,
you know,
Charlatan or fraudster or whatever
that's trying to steal your money.
But I think there was an
element of that in this thing.
And I think the landmark forum was a
very, very intense program. I mean,
you're in this room,
it's a kind of conference room and
you're there for a very long hours.
You have very limited
breaks. Um, your, you know,
it's till 10 o'clock at night and you're
just getting all this information and
everybody's sharing these incredibly dark
moments from their lives and you feel
very, very vulnerable, you
know, and those moments.
And then they come in at just
the crucial moment and say, well,
maybe you'd like to sign up for
the next course and you not,
you're whipping about, they had a
terrible childhood and whatever,
and you're like, okay, whatever, whatever,
I'll pay whatever it takes. And you know,
I, it was a very powerful emotional
experience being there, you know,
and not necessarily
for the good, that's for
sure. Was there a for a time,
because I imagined in
researching this book,
you want it to you as much information.
He's good. Was ever a time where like,
I don't want to go to another
self up for them and yeah,
but you force yourself to do so.
Yeah. I mean, what the, you
know, it's funny it, the deed,
when it came to the landmark forum,
I actually did the landmark forum before
the bucket kind of went the other way
round. And that was one of the things,
you know, everyone had told me, you know,
do this thing. It's amazing. It's amazing.
Amazing, amazing. You've got to go.
And it was partly,
it was sort of almost the other way
round that I did the forum thinking, um,
just because I'd want it to be happier,
you know,
I was kind of lonely and
my new country and um,
and I went and that was part of what led
to the book rather than the other way
around. But yeah, I'm in through email.
Debus I did a lot of this kind of
mindfulness workshops. I did meditation,
I did various things and a lot of
the time I did sort of say, Oh God,
not another one.
But you know,
at the same time I want it
to be open to these things.
I didn't want to start from the position
that this is all a load of rubbish and
you know, just, you know,
w I wanted to see what,
what actually worked and what didn't.
Um, and, and you bring
up a good point too,
and the majority of people that are maybe
going to a self folk forum or reading
a book about self help or an
actual need of help or other,
or are seeking some kind of answers
from the people that you interacted with
from people that you met. Do they,
they find answers in these books? Um,
did they, did they experience
some kind of transformation?
Well, I think a lot of people
do. I mean, that's an atmosphere,
kind of like a tent revival. And there's
a lot of these places where it's like,
ah, yes. And everyone gets whipped
up into this kind of [inaudible].
And then the most successful people in
this industry are the people who can
really prey on those emotions and kind of
whip people up into a kind of a frenzy.
And I think people do
feel very transformed.
But then one of their kind of depressing
statistics is that the most likely
customer of a self help book is
somebody who's bought another self help.
But within the last 18 months.
So there's obviously something where
people get on it kind of spiral and you
know,
none of these things are
actually providing quite
the answers that the people
are hoping for. And I think, you know,
you raised an interesting point when you
said these are the people who need help.
There's something about
in this whole idea it,
so it's a very American idea in a way.
This idea that our happiness is
something that we can control, you know,
that self help, you know, rather
than helping others or that you know,
that help should be provided from some
other source or that you are entitled to
help. It's like, you know,
go out and help yourself and pull
yourself up by your bootstraps and make
yourself happier. I don't know if you've
ever seen these memes that say, you know,
happiness is a choice. You know,
there's a quite a common phrase here.
It's almost like if you don't,
you know,
it's your responsibility to
make yourself happier. Yeah.
Which can be quite insanity
inducing in itself.
And that's, that's definitely
an interesting point you
bring up in the book,
which is that in America it seems that
we're really seeking ice happiness in
isolation.
Yeah.
And is that starkly different from your
experiences not having lived in the
country?
Well,
so this is one of the things that I
cat's coming back to in my research,
which is that pretty much every piece
of research that's ever been done and to
human happiness and no matter how much
that all these studies all kind of
contradicted themselves in other ways.
There is one factor that we know is like
the single biggest cause of happiness
and that is our social connections
or relationships with other people,
but yet the south hop industry and are
kind of conception of happiness is moving
more and more and more towards
being about the self. And you know,
a lot of the activities that we're
taking part in now like meditation,
like mindfulness, like
yoga, like you know,
they're all about having a very private
emotional experience about looking
within your soul and Gina being
internal rather than external.
And I think that's one of the,
one of the real problems.
I think that was one of the key findings
that really made me think, okay,
this might be where we're going
slightly wrong. And you know,
I think it's a trend that's true
in other western countries as well.
We're living increasingly
isolated lives. But, um,
I think in America there's
a very individualistic
culture and I think that is,
you know, and our approach
to happiness is, you know,
me and my happiness journey and my quest
for happiness and how can I make myself
happier, which is probably going
about it in slightly the wrong way.
And I've only really first and needing
to listen to the stories that you bring
up specifically the grown a yoga and
meditation help people would be so doing
that four or five yoga classes a week
to try and get that sense of fulfillment
and happiness and mindfulness. Um, and it,
it had kind of opened the door to maybe
a different world than, than I would see.
Cause I don't know many friends that
are doing yoga on a day to day basis in
order to view your content through
in order to build that happiness. Um,
from what you saw,
do you think that maybe,
I don't know if extreme is the right word,
but where they extreme
examples of the Sikh,
is this the seeking out of there
can cause, yeah. I mean, you know,
I don't want to give the wrong impression
that I think that yoga is the cause of
all the problems because
obviously that's not true.
But I think it's about a kind of mindset.
I think California is kind of the world
headquarters of self actualization,
isn't it? So I think the things
that you see here in California,
and maybe a little, oh a little more
extreme than you would see elsewhere,
but these trends do hold true. You
know, across the country. You know,
you think about Oprah and the influence
that she's had and it's all about,
you know, my personal
happiness journey and you know,
my own responsibility for my happiness.
And you know, a lot of these, um,
you know, these, the, the whole sort
of yoga, mindfulness meditation,
what I've come to think of as the
spiritual industrial complex, I mean,
that is worth about $20 billion to
the economy. I mean, it's, it's,
it's a lot of money changing
hands it units, it's very popular.
So these self help forums, you've
software books are to a degree useful,
but maybe not there. Maybe will
hold all the answers for us. Right.
From your research, what do you think
could lead Americans to have your life?
Well, I think that what I found,
just again and again and again,
whether that was through the kind of
field work or the academic staff or
whatever,
is that the key to happiness really
is in relationships and other people.
And you know,
I could say this all the time and one of
the most common responses that I get is
people say, well, you
know, that's fair enough,
but that doesn't apply to me because
I'm an introvert and I hate other people
and you know, rather just sit in my
basement. That ends to it. I'd never,
never talked to anyone, but actually
all the research supports that, uh,
the fact that the,
the importance of social connection is
just as true and important for introverts
as it is for extroverts. It might manifest
in a slightly different way. You know,
it might not be going to lots of huge
parties and being the center of attention,
but I'm still,
you know,
the importance of having supportive
relationships is just an author.
It's not just for our happiness,
it's for our health. Um, um,
low social connection or loneliness is,
has carries with it.
I risk of premature death comparable to
that of smoking and it's about twice as
dangerous to be lonely as it
is to be a base, you know,
and you think how much money and effort
we put into dieting and not big on base,
you know, when actually, you know, here's,
here's an answer, which is so important.
Right?
Yeah.
There was an interesting part of the,
um,
at the end of the book talking about the
genetic component of happiness and how
you kind of have this like biological
marker of where you're going to always be
happy and then you can have your words.
Was there ever any information or studies
that you've found that showed maybe
that that fulfillment and that the
biological market could be tweaked upward?
Not, not necessarily change?
Yeah, at the baseline,
but like social interactions with the
things that made that mark or move up?
I don't even know if it's measurable.
Yes.
I mean,
I think there's been various ways to
measure it and I think that people are
generally agreed that there's a
big genetic component to happiness.
So people have a kind of happiness
set point that they keep returning to.
But you can kind of walk around it a bit.
What were the whole positive psychology
movement has become slightly political,
slightly ideological is that it very much
downplays the idea of circumstances on
our happiness. I'm very much plays
up the idea of individual control.
So there's a lot of research
now and it's kind of,
a lot of it is funded by a very right
wing by a very what right wing bias
organization that this
belief that you know,
we can kind of is this bit straps idea
that we can make ourselves happier by,
by trying all this stuff and you know,
it's kind of your responsibility
and if you're not happy,
it's almost like it's your own fault
and downplays all these factors like,
you know, um, income, race, social
class, you know, so social projects,
which actually is not a fair reading. I
don't, I believe it's based on a very,
very fluid reading of the,
of the data.
And actually circumstances
do make a huge difference.
So maybe a, an an open ended question is
we have all these things. We have yoga,
we have, we have meditation
to, to build mindfulness. Um,
religion is something that you discussed,
you and that religious people
are statistically more happy,
but maybe in real life those statistics
don't necessarily hit all the actual,
the reality with, with all
of these things. Um, how,
how do they get built into a happy
life while also maintaining it? Yeah.
Well,
the religion thing that you just mentioned
is really interesting because across
the world it's, it's pretty robust
finding that religious people do, right?
As happier than nonreligious people.
And I think the temptation is to think
that that is because people have this
kind of private belief in God and this,
this certainty that things will be okay
because there's an afterlife or whatever.
But when you control for the fact that
religious people have much greater number
and quality of social connections,
when you control for that in the study,
it's the difference disappears.
So actually the reason why religious
people tend to rate us happier than other
people is because they have such a
strong sense of community generally.
And when I went to spend
time with movements in Utah,
that was a huge finding.
You know,
I was staying with a Mormon family and
we were sitting there for half an hour
and their living room.
And I think 10 different people stop by
for drop off some cookies or a cup of
tea, not a cup of tea.
They don't drink tea,
but that's my Britishness and whatever,
you know, a drink or something.
And you know,
so I think it is that sense of community
that really is at the heart of why
religion, you know, does
it make people happier? Um,
so maybe,
uh,
a point for the audience as a guardians
of technology at Google arbiters of new
things. One recommendations
would you have to us as we,
as we build technology for people,
um, from what you've seen in terms of,
in terms of happiness,
one of the key things that
we say at Google is like
gold to me that someone will
look to use. Um, almost like a toothbrush
experience. It's kind of when things,
it's like you want to use them,
you wanted to use it every single
day cause they love it so much.
It's so useful when we're building these
things. What should we be considering?
Wow, that's a big question. I, if I,
if I knew that I'd be making a lot
more money than I, than I am now. Um,
I think,
you know,
technology is a competitive thing because
it can be a force for connection and
bringing people together.
And it can also be a force for isolating
people as well and keeping people
locked in their own smartphone
and not, I've been, um,
this is not Google, but I
remember one of the, you know,
one of these moments when I was
researching, there's Burke and I thought,
oh my God,
do you know this is the end
of civilization was when
I downloaded a happiness
app to my phone and I went onto the
APP store and there's like a thousand
different options for happiness apps
that you can eat conducted, you know,
they'll,
you know,
send you pictures of sunsets
and puppies and beaches and,
and there was this one liquid,
you know,
send you pictures of your own loved ones
so that you could kind of sit looking
at your phone, scrolling through
pictures of your loved ones. Well,
presumably your actual loved ones.
I like looking at pictures of you maybe,
I don't know,
on their phone.
And I remember there was this one time
when the one that I downloaded actually
we'd send you these kind of positive
affirmations every hour or so throughout
the day. And you're supposed to repeat
them. So it was, you know, I am beautiful,
I am enough for whatever it was.
And I remember like the problem was
every time my phone buzzed when I got a
message from this thing,
I get that Pavlovian kind of jealous of,
Oh someone sending me a
message. Great. You know,
somebody wants to go out and
meet for coffee or you know,
it's a friend or whatever. And then
it would say, you know, I am enough.
And I think the cross the cross the
thing, cause the whole point is, you know,
I am not enough and I think
if we are really looking to,
to an APP to make us happy
that something's gone.
And then just kind of put a little bit
on the research you did around social
media. Have you found that, um,
at least in your research that a lot
of people have replaced those in person
connections, those interpersonal
connections with your phone,
with your application?
Yeah,
I think that's quite good evidence to
show that that has definitely happened.
And especially for the kind of
millennials and younger generation,
I think there is a lot of um,
concern over the fact that people are
replacing real world interactions with
online once you know, smartphone.
Yeah. Thanks for sure.
Cool. Well I think we're going to open
it up to questions from the audience. Um,
and as well as on the dory. Uh,
Alison, if he's still in the room, uh,
I think he has a mic that he can
pass around. I think someone had fun.
Hi. Oh, hi. Oh, so one of the
topics that you kind of pointed out,
like regarding this whole stress of
trying to be happy is like the whole like
self help community and like
whatever. But like, yeah. Oh,
also the other thing I kind of I'm
curious about is like what about the
contribution of the family? Like,
because like one of the things I see, I,
I could be wrong,
but my understanding is also like we are
in this trend where like probably the
kids are being like either or pamper,
like this whole notion of having any
kind of negative emotion is like, oh,
something is like extremely wrong.
Rather than just teaching them,
it's just part of life and like, yes, oh,
you need to just go through it and like
kind of teach them how to handle it.
So yeah.
Oh,
how much is that also contributing and
creating like generations of people who
are like kind of probably
extremely confused about
what is right.
It's an excellent point.
I actually wrote a whole chapter
about parenting and, sorry,
I lost my thing here. So sorry. Um, yeah,
I write a whole chapter in the book
about parenting and exactly what you're
describing. I think
there's this, you know,
in the same way that there's this feeling
that we can kind of force ourselves to
be happy with enough hard work.
There's also a kind of parallel feeling
that we can kind of build this half a
happy child,
that if we just make every moment
kind of magical and we take away every
negative sense and every negative emotion,
prioritize positivity above all else,
then we will turn out this perfectly
happy kids and it's backfiring, you know,
really badly.
I mean,
some of the examples that I came
across when most of the book,
we're actually quite ridiculous and
humorous. You know that there was this,
one thing I was so shocked by when I
first moved here was that a friend of mine
left her two year old,
I think two and a half year old with
another mom while she went to run some
errands and this woman,
the other woman breastfed
this friend's child,
this friends to road because she was
crying. He does it was this, this villain,
there's talk can't be distressed for for
one moment without somebody stepping.
I mean,
that's a very extreme example,
but I think that is this sort of data
that we've become, or you know, I'm a,
I'm a parent and I know that I'm part of
this and it's hard to get away from it,
but yeah, we have become these
helicopter parents who, um,
sort of micromanaging our
kids' lives and then the,
the evidence is showing that kids in
college now are actually suffering some
really serious mental health problems, you
know, so it's severe levels of anxiety,
depression, lack of resilience,
those kinds of things.
And I think those trends are,
are related for sure.
Okay. Hi, I
took a class at Google
called search inside yourself
about a year ago. Um, it's,
uh, I don't know if you
call it a self help class.
It does include some meditation.
Um,
but I think the biggest takeaway I had
from it was a piece of advice that was
don't aim for a happy life, aim
for a meaningful life. Right.
So is that something that you found is
you should look for meeting instead of
looking for happiness?
Yeah. So I think it's really, I mean,
I haven't done that course so I can't
speak to exactly what was discussed. That,
and I think meaning is
obviously really important.
And I think connection is the
thing that's most important.
I think in a way there's this trend
where meanings become the new happiness.
Everyone's testing
meaning meaning meaning,
and then it kind of loses its meaning
because what is meaning meaning is
something that's different to
everything else. And I think when it's,
when there's this kind of MacGuffin this
thing that we're all supposed to chase
after, then it becomes its own rat race.
But yes, I think you're right that,
that it's,
um,
it's important to see what things have
value in our lives and just for happiness
to be a kind of byproduct of our lives
and living a connected meaningful life
rather than chasing after happiness.
Specifically,
you touched upon briefly the connection
between religious people being more
happy because of social gatherings.
And you elaborate a bit more
on that correlation. Like
what exactly causes that?
Why does social connection?
Because religious people that I'm
happy because of their social, yeah.
Well, I think that there's lots of
research that shows that people who have a
religious affiliation,
um,
spans more time socializing
and being part of a community.
And it's not necessarily,
you know,
that they go and more
dinner dates or whatever,
but it is that if you have a religious
place where you go every week, you know,
if you go to church or mosque or
synagogue or whatever, you know,
that's very much based on community
and it's based on this kind of shared
understanding that people are responsible
for each other's welfare and people
will look out for each other.
You know,
not every religious
community is like that,
but I think that's a kind of
baseline. And so people, you know,
and there's research that
shows that people who are
religious are more likely to
do things like give blood and uh,
more likely to,
to be involved in community events,
to have
more social events per week
then than other people.
And I think that's why
when you control for that,
when you take that out of the equation,
then actually religious people aren't any
happier than, than anybody else. Got It.
Thank you. Thanks. Hey, thanks for coming.
So you've been talking a lot
about the happiness aspect,
but you also mentioned the
term self actualized. Yeah. Uh,
and I was Kinda curious to hear your
perspective on how you view the difference
between those two and come to
the point of out of cheese,
like a life of trying to find meaning.
What about like an effort to try
and get to better know yourself, uh,
do that self actualized term.
Yep.
Yeah.
So I think it's about balance because
obviously getting to know who you are and
you know,
becoming the best self that you can be,
all of those things are important and to,
to work out who you are and how to
work with that. But that's very,
very important. But I think what's
happened in America is that we've,
the balance has somehow got out of whack.
So we're putting self
actualization above connection.
So the idea was that we kind of
engineer happiness from the inside out.
That if you can perfectly know
yourself and understand yourself,
I don't know if you've heard this phrase,
happiness comes from within.
It's actually impossible to do to get a
result on a Google search that tells you
the opposite. Because I typed in in
our happiness, I was going to do some,
at one point, I was going to think of
Dang some slides for this and I typed in,
you know,
meme happiness comes from within.
If you've got a thousand
results of all these, you know,
different that memes sort
of same variations on this.
If you type in meme in an image search,
happiness comes from other people.
Every single result seemingly,
or at least on the front page that comes
back says happiness does not come from
other people having a
discussion with them.
And it's almost like that's how I
think the balance has got robbed.
So I'm not saying that people should not,
you know,
tried to understand themselves,
reflect on themselves, all of that.
That's obviously important,
but I think the emphasis has got
wrong some somewhere, you know,
I think if we make connection and other
people are starting point and then throw
in a bit of self actualization
rather than, you know,
having the balance so skewed
the other way. Thanks. Hi.
So you were talking about the
importance of social connections.
I think there are two types. I can
imagine. First there, for example,
close friends who I spend a lot of time
with and I have deep connection and then
there are just, just people
I barely know. Yeah. So, uh,
it just hard to have many close
friends because it's like,
it takes a lot of time, but you can
have a lot of people you barely know.
Is there any distinctions which type of
relationships is more like what's the
difference between them and how do they
influence happiness in different ways,
close relationships and more meaningful
or just know as many people as you can
actually important surprise in it.
So it goes without saying.
I think that close friendships and
really supportive relationships are more
important than,
you know,
the women who sells a your newspaper
in the morning or whatever. But um,
and that's really the key is sort of
focusing on a few very close supportive
relationships. Ah, there is pretty good
evidence to show that having lots of um,
uh,
what there is a technical term for it,
but it's sort of small social connections
also and being part of a wider
community and feeling invested in a
community also has a big impact on our
happiness as well. So you know,
just feeling that we're, we're,
we're part of something
bigger than ourselves I think.
So I think an aggregate unit might not
be that every single one of those little
connections really is,
is that meaningful.
But overall I think they
can make a big difference.
And I thought that there was a,
an interesting point in the book,
not to give too many details away,
but you kind of quote Thomas Jefferson
in the pursuit of happiness and in your
interpretation it's not so much
pursuing this inward happiness,
which is kind of is perfected
from all my self actualization,
but rather pursuing a happiness
which makes you part of a community.
It makes you part of that larger hole.
Yes. I mean, I think that's,
that's pretty clear that the founding
fathers weren't really thinking about a
self help workshop when they eat. I mean
there's taking it straight, but yes,
they were talking about kind of civic
engagement and community and that was very
much being part a kind
of part of a larger,
okay, cool. That's just, yeah. Hi. Um,
wonder if you can read your book feet
touching that or what'd you think about,
what are you notice I'm not
from here either. Uh, and um,
I wonder if you've noticed that there's
some, seems to be some bragging around
mentioning or just even implying that
you're busy and people, you know,
it's just fun. I find it very hard here
to just call a friend up and say, Hey,
here you go for a beer. Nice.
Almost. It's virtually impossible.
And where I come from, it's like, you
know, we're adults, we have these lives.
But yeah, it's just
easier. And, and I, I've,
I've almost become that
and myself to where
I have to kids and you know, and
I work full time. And so, yeah,
it's also hard for me sometimes,
but I get the sense too that sometimes
that I feel this inner pride of saying,
well, you know, no, I'm VC
tonight. It's not, can make
it work or not. And I'm like,
Oh yeah, yeah, I'm, I'm, I'm going
to be the person. And then I'm like,
that feels like shit. I haven't had
a beer in a long time, would anyone,
and I dunno.
Yeah.
I mean it's so easy to
purchase socializing down to
the absolute bottom of their
priority list, isn't it? I mean, you
know, if you have a full time job,
you work hard. I think there's this, I
mean, we didn't actually talk about this,
but it's something that we touched,
I touched on in the book that now what
used to be called work life balance,
they're now calling work life integration,
you know,
which it just makes my heart sing.
I used to be more work that you have
to have your phone on all the time,
that your answer, boy,
you're always on the clock.
And that we're kind of merging
all these parts of our lives.
So there's very little socializing
or communicating or whatever with,
with friends that is totally free of
work and free and responsibilities in the
way that perhaps it used to be.
And I mean there's this really
just sort of chilling I thought,
chilling statistic, which is the, um,
I don't know if you've heard of
the American time use survey,
but they just categorize
how people literally spend
every moment of that day and
every activity that you can think of,
you know, working, sleeping, drive, him,
having sex, whatever,
it's all categorized.
And there's a category on
the survey called socializing
and communicating and it
doesn't just cover the good stuff.
So it's not just the United,
the lovely heart to heart that you
have with your best friend or their,
there's door in compensation with deal
with your boyfriend or girlfriend.
It's like all the arguing then lighting
the bitching and whining, everything, oh,
thrown in together.
So as long as there's one more
than one adult present and um,
it's not an incidental
part of something else.
Does anyone want to hazard a guess how
much time we spend on that category per
day?
The average American.
Hmm.
Yeah. It's about 30 minutes a day.
So put another way, you know, we,
we know this is the single most important
sort of pillar of our happiness,
but yet we spent 23 and a half hours
out of every day not doing that in know,
doing something completely different.
So, you know, I found that pretty scary.
Hi. Hi. Thanks for your talk. Um,
did you happen to see the article in
the New York Times magazine this last
weekend? It was called the kids who
can't just kind of like a Meta title. Oh,
I don't think so.
It was about an anxiety with millennials
and especially the youngest millennials.
Um, it was saying that, you know,
it's talking about this phenomenon.
So first of all,
I wondered if you came across this in
your research anxiety being a bigger
problem with younger people. Yes,
definitely. And then, you know, hazard,
any guesses at how to explain it and
mentioned the social media phenomenon,
which I think is right on the money.
And you touched on that. Yeah.
But another thing I talked about was how,
I don't love this word,
but it says that,
uh,
it said that the youngest people were
being cuddled in the sense that it's
common now if a kid's feeling anxious,
that they're just allowed to
stay on from school. Yeah.
Or that they have their own like dedicated
entrance to avoid the stressors of
the main entrance at school.
Yes.
And that was one of the ideas that was
put forward as to why does actually
having a negative effect and keeping
them in this like spiral of anxiety.
So I wonder what you thought about,
yeah, I think that's absolutely
right. I mean, I, and I
notice it in myself as well.
You know, I have two kids and um,
in know my, my, what, my oldest son,
he goes to this kind of drama grade
partner on a Thursday and he decided he
doesn't like it and he doesn't want to
go and that he's got some anxiety around
that and it's an, I take into
like, oh, we've got to stop him.
He doesn't have to go, well, you know,
why should he have to go to that?
And you know, it's, it's very
easy to, to think, you know,
and I was about to pull them out of this
thing and the hell am I doing, you know,
I mean is there,
you know,
and I send it back to my
[inaudible] probably a good 70,
80% of the stuff that I didn't really
want to be doing that much. And you know,
nobody was suggesting that I would
not be doing it because of that.
I knew that there's a balance and,
and whatever.
And I think it's good that we consider
kids failings more now and that we
consider their emotions and treat them as
important. And I, I do think that, but,
but absolutely I think there is this
tendency and this idea that everything has
to be magical and wonderful for kids
and that we remove negative experiences
from their path. You know, that
the is very damaging for sure.
Yeah.
How you doing? Thanks for coming. Um,
so my question actually kind of relation
to that right there along with the
gentleman's question.
Never hear about it shrank the
connection and also time usage.
So you talk about the sense
of community obviously and uh,
to go along with these younger
generations kind of being a little more
hyperactive or something, these
social media and everything. Um, it's,
it seems to be like a stereotype
type of millennials that there add,
they can't keep their
attention for anything.
So this idea of fragmentation of not
only your working life balance and
everything, but also your
personal interest. Um,
do you find any correlation between
simplification of kind of kin or really
focusing on a specific
interest of yours, um, in,
in regards to this idea of like
having too many communities are to me,
friendships that you don't actually
get the value out of it that you might,
or is there a threshold or correlation
at this idea of that, you know,
at some of these less developed countries
have less things to worry about?
Not necessarily lessons were about and
very important things to worry about,
but this idea that maybe they're
just not overexerting where they,
where their interests lie and trying to
do too much or have too many communities
to really get invested in.
Yeah.
Too much choice. And I
think that is, you know,
we live in this very consumerist world
whether we have so much choice for
everything all the time. And I think
that can sometimes be paralyzing.
That if you can be anything,
you know,
if we were all told you that be whatever
you want to be, follow your passion,
you know, find your, find your path,
you know, you can, you can do anything.
I think sometimes you kind of think,
oh my God,
I can't do anything because it's just,
you know,
the expectation is so high of what
happiness should look like and you know,
there's so many choices,
so many demands on our time and attention.
I think absolutely that it,
it can be quite paralyzing.
Yeah. Sorry, just super
quick followup meaning, um,
more specifically like do you think that
there's value in trying to find a few
interests as opposed to kind of
just diversifying that a bit? Okay.
That's interesting. Yeah. I don't know.
I didn't look into that specifically,
but I think that probably depends
on the individual as well.
I think some people you know really have
a very deep and abiding passion for one
thing and that really brings
them happiness and meaning
to, to, to follow that.
And other people will try lots of
different things throughout the course of
light. And same with friendships. I think
somebody over here have asked about,
you asked about, um, you know, is it one
handful of close friends or is it nothing,
lots and lots of people.
And I think that is to do with individual
personality really what it comes down
to.
Cool. Um, any more live questions? If not,
we can go to the dory for one or two.
Oh, I think, yeah, yeah, yeah. Yeah.
I was actually curious about what
you found when you were reading.
Um, because I actually, I'm
like a natural born cynic
generally when it comes
to things like this.
But I went to a talk here
actually last month, um,
this guy named Daniel Gorman.
And it was really interesting and
actually kind of skewed me towards,
he came with the gun,
other neuroscience.
He came with a neuroscientist and
they basically had done research where
meditation and this
practice of mindfulness. Um,
there was data done where they looked at
the brains of monks and it showed that
it actually decreased, you know,
stress. And there was just,
and that's actually the same book we were
talking about before. Altered traits.
Yeah. And so I guess I was curious in
your own findings, you know, this is
so,
this isn't really,
this has been one of the most
controversial things actually, that I'm,
this whole thing about meditation.
Every time I ever bring up meditation,
I get a million emails
from angry meditators.
All of the world's wanting
to run me out of that.
So I think there's a few things that
I think neuroscience is much more
complicated than popular neuroscience
would allow us to believe.
So when we say something changes the
brain, it sounds amazingly impressive,
but pretty much everything we do
changes the brain. So you know,
from going to the bathroom or to, you
know, sitting here now to hear, you know,
hearing your questions,
everything we do.
So the changes the brain because
that's the nature of, of brain.
But so meditation and mindfulness,
there have been many thousands of studies
done into the effects of these things.
And the results have been,
I would say from my experience that,
not that there are no
effects of these things,
but they have been quite
strongly overhyped.
So there was a metro analysis
that came out a year or two ago,
which looked at all of these studies and
found that out of something like 1800
studies, only 40 of them actually
had a control comparison group.
So I don't know how much people know
about how these kinds of studies work,
but you know,
sort of comparing a group of people who
meditates or group of people who don't
do anything isn't really a fair
comparison because you know,
there's so many other factors
that could be going on.
They could be placebo effect, it
could be the effect of, you know,
having a social connection,
whatever.
When Meditation is compared to a control
group where they are doing something
comparable, you know, a
reasonable control group,
meditation performance no better and
often worse than than something like
exercise,
listening to spiritual audio tapes.
Um, any kind of sham control
where you're just, you know,
putting something to
be a control condition.
So I think we need to
approach it with caution,
which isn't to say that for many people,
you know, it's an extremely meaningful,
an important part of their
day and something that they
really get a lot from and
that's great. But I think once we start
rolling out as the answer to everything,
then that's where it becomes problematic.
Sorry, one more question. So in your foe,
so while you're writing this
book and doing research,
was there anything that
you found was effective?
Yeah, I mean I think it
comes back, you know,
this is just keep banging on
about the same thing in a really,
it does come down to to um,
connecting with other people and
doing that in a way that's most
meaningful to you. But um, you know, but
literally spending more time, you know,
seeing that we spent half an
hour of our day socializing,
communicating as opposed to three hours
watching television or being on the
internet or whatever and actually just
try and to upsize minutes, you know,
to just spend more time doing it and
sort of nurture the relationships that we
have.
I think that really is the far and away
the best thing you can do for your own
happiness. Sorry to clarify, I meant out
of all these kinds of help. Help. Thanks.
Yeah. Yeah. Huh. That's an interesting,
you know, I think a lot of the things,
a lot of these self help things it dead.
They were one or two points within them.
They were interesting and that I took
away and thought about some more.
And you know,
there were things in the landmark forum,
there were things from mindfulness that
I think in certain situations can be
useful.
But I think overall any one package
of solutions I think is usually over
promising quite heavily.
And so there was no one book or apple
costs or whatever that I could say,
okay, well the answer is
this in a because it didn't,
it didn't really feel that way to me.
Cool. I need more live questions.
Sure. Cool. We'll go to a,
one of the door to questions
then when measuring happiness,
how do you correct it?
Yeah.
There's a question that have is how do
you correct for cultural differences and
what being someone very et cetera happy.
Um,
I guess maybe how do you, has your id
measure for cultural differences? Yeah.
Happiness.
It's a really interesting
question. I mean, there's, um,
there's a lot of research on this
because people are in different cultures
define happiness in slightly
different ways. And I think, um, they,
uh, people in the west tend to
favor, there's a word for it,
which has gone from my mind,
but very high energy kind of emotions,
like exhilaration and excitement
in a real sort of extreme emotions.
And I think maybe in some other
cultures they value our calm,
I kind of contentment,
whatever.
There was some really fascinating research
that came out of UC Berkeley recently,
which looked at how have people define
happiness in different countries around
the world and hey, how they
defined it. And then B,
how happy, you know, how happy
they were. And they found that,
um,
in parts of East Asia and in Russia,
I think that people define happiness
in a much more collective way.
So they didn't really see it as a kind
of individual pursuit in the same way
that we do in the u s but
they're still at Maura's.
I kind of socially orientated endeavor.
And for those people, the more they,
if you define happiness in that way,
the more you perceived happiness,
the happier you became.
Whereas in the u s where people define
happiness in a more individualistic way,
the more you pursue happiness,
the less happy you become.
So it's kind of the opposite way.
Super Fascinating. Yeah. I'm just cool.
Well, Hey, thank you for coming here
and thank you for speaking with us. Oh,
thanks for having me.
It's wonderful. Thank you.